History is full of horrifying events, some
of which are truly more terrifying than any
fictional story.
Here's some true stories from History that
will chill you to the bone.
1.
The Italian Renaissance was a period in Italy's
history of outstanding art and culture.
This 200 year period gave birth to some of
the greatest artists and artworks humanity
has ever known, such as Leonardo Da Vinci
and Michelangelo.
But it also gave birth to something considerably
more gruesome, a plague of real life zombies.
In 1494 was the first major outbreak of syphilis.
Before antibiotics were invented syphilis
was a fatal infection something to be gravely
feared.
The disease slowly ate away at the victims
face, causing their flesh to fall away resulting
in the complete destruction of their face
and genitals, within just a few months, and
death would follow shortly afterwards.
During this period it was not uncommon to
see Frenchmen and Italians walking around
with half their face falling off and their
bare skulls exposed, just like a scene from
a horrific zombie movie.
Thank god for modern medicine.
2.
Henry Howard Holmes, better known as H.H.
Holmes is widely known as one of America's
first serial killers.
His body count is thought to be somewhere
between 27 and 200.
He achieved this by building a hotel in a
bustling part of Chicago in the 1890s.
And designed it to be the perfect killing
arena to fulfil his sick desires.
It later came to be known as "Murder Castle".
H.H. Holmes meticulously designed the hotel
to be a complex maze of windowless rooms.
He even hired a handful of different builders
to construct the hotel in sections so only
Holmes would know the layout.
Making escape virtually impossible for his
victims.
Every inch of the hotel was designed to confuse
and terrify his victims.
Including doors that only opened from the
outside.
Doorways that opened onto brick walls.
A safe big enough to put a person inside to
slowly suffocate them.
And a chute that allowed Holmes to dump bodies
from the upper floors to the basement, where
two massive furnaces and a large supply of
flesh stripping acid was stored.
3.
The Roman city of Pompeii was once one of
the greatest civilisations on Earth, unfortunately
it is most famously known for disaster that
occurred there in 79 AD.
When Italy's Mount Vesuvius erupted, wiping
out Pompeii and burying it in ash for over
a millennium.
But even worse effected by the eruption was
Pompeii's neighbouring city Herculaneum.
Just like Pompeii, Herculaneum was also spectacularly
and horrifically buried in volcanic ash.
But Herculaneum suffered a fate much worse
than it's more famous neighbour.
Herculaneum was also hit by a superheated
pyroclastic flow which is a fast moving current
of hot gas and rock spewed out from a volcano
that reaches speeds of 450 mph.
But the most deadly thing about this volcanic
death cloud is that it can reach temperatures
of up to 1,000 degrees Celsius.
It's incredible speed meant the whole city
would have been engulfed by a 1,000 degree
cloud of gas in just seconds.
This caused what must have been one of the
most horrific sights in history.
The human skull is full of liquids and if
you heat it up super quickly it explodes.
This is exactly what happened at Herculaneum
in 79 AD.
The 1,000 degree volcanic cloud caused peoples
skin to vaporise, their brains to boil and
their skulls to literally explode, all in
under a second.
Which sounds like a very good reason not to
live next to an active volcano.
Although this doesn't seem to have got through
to the residents of Naples.
4.
During World War II countless atrocities happened
to humans, but animals received their share
of suffering too.
In the 1939, during the run-up to World War
II, the British government formed the National
Air Raid Precautions Animals Committee.
The purpose of the committee was to decide
what people should do with their pets once
war broke out.
The biggest concern is that food shortages
would be made even worse due to people feeding
their pets.
So to solve the problem the government sent
out pamphlets called "Advice to Animal Owners".
It featured an advertisement for a specific
type of gun, which was best suited to killing
animals and guidelines on how to humanely
dispose of your pet.
Within a week of the campaign being launched
750,000 pets across the British isles had
been killed by their owners or taken to purpose
built pet disposal centres.
It has come to be known as the Pet Holocaust.
5.
One of the most horrific stories from all
of history was the Nanking Massacre.
During the Second Sino-Japanese War in 1937
the Japanese Imperial Army captured the Chinese
city of Nanking, which was then the Chinese
capital.
Over a period of six weeks an estimated 300,000
un-armed Chinese civilians were slaughtered
by the Imperial Japanese Army.
But it get's worse, the horrific event is
also widely known as the Rape of Nanking.
Because the Japanese forces raped and looted
most of the city's residents before killing
them.
The Japanese soldiers even raped infants and
the elderly as well as forcing citizens to
commit incestuous acts and many other atrocities
on their fellow Chinese citizens.
Ever since the massacre, in attempts to maintain
their pride Japanese officials have outright
denied that the event ever happened, claiming
it was a complete fabrication and an attempt
at anti-Japanese propaganda.